d'accord qu'avez-vous obtenu de vincenti
minelli
et qu'avez-vous obtenu de judy garland
qu'est-ce qu'ils vous ont donné
je pense que j'ai eu
mes rêves de mon père
et ma conduite de ma mère qui avez-
vous admiré
quand vous étiez enfant je veux dire qui  étaient
vos idoles
elvis presley j'aimais beaucoup
et puis j'aimais les choses étranges parce que
nous avions toujours de la musique différente dans notre
maison
nous avions du jazz dans une pièce, montrons de la musique dans
une autre pièce
et puis quand ma sœur et mon frère et
moi où était j'étais rock et  rouler tu as dit une fois
que j'étais la mère de ma mère
qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire tu sais je ne pense pas
que je suis inhabituel ou différent de
pratiquement tous les enfants que je connais à un
moment donné se sont sentis comme leurs parents
parent parce que tu veux protéger et
tu veux  prendre soin de
toi et tu veux aider et tu veux être
considéré comme responsable aussi
alors tu te mets soudainement dans la
position d'agir comme un parent
ouais je peux creuser quand as-tu dit à
ta mère que
je ne peux pas venir à ton mariage mais  je serai
là pour le ni  ght
avec une histoire raconte quelle était cette histoire
oh c'est un jour terrible
euh elle m'a appelé de londres
et m'a dit que tu devais venir je vais me
marier et c'est très important que
moi et moi je ne pensais pas tu sais quoi
je ne pensais tout simplement pas
et j'ai dit maman je ne peux pas venir
cette fois mais je te promets que je viendrai
au prochain
et il y a eu un silence au téléphone
et puis j'ai entendu ça
et elle a commencé à rire et nous sommes
devenus hystériques  elle devait avoir un assez bon
sens de l'humour ta mère
qu'est-ce que tu te dis tous les
matins quand tu te regardes dans le
miroir on y va encore oh je sais ce que tu veux dire
tu crois toujours que tu étais si si
tu étais aussi belle que raquel  welch
tu pourrais régner sur le monde donne-moi dix
minutes pour ressembler à racquel chérie galloise fais
attention
je veux dire tu sais donnons-lui un
peu plus de 10 minutes peut-être ne
plaisantons-nous pas juste 10 minutes 9 11.
étais-tu amoureux de robert  de niro
quand tu tournais new york new york
non  j'étais amoureux de son talent
et vous savez ses pensées et le cerveau
est une zone érogène donc
nous nous entendions très bien ces fourmis ennuyeuses que
j'ai jamais entendues ce n'est pas ce que je
vous ai demandé je vous ai demandé de la saleté et vous
donnez  moi euh
un autre est la société jet set la
décadence divine dont sally bowles a
parlé cabaret
je n'ai jamais vu ce que j'ai lu j'aimerais le
voir
mais je veux dire je tu sais que j'ai peut être
bu mais je n'aurais pas pu  j'ai tout raté
je veux dire ce n'est pas vraiment si
excitant j'ai entendu dire que tu as vu un peu plus
que ça d'
accord liza écoute les résultats de ton dernier album
qu'est-ce que ça fait
de passer de sammy davis jr frank sinatra
las vegas
monte carlo aux pet shop boys  le
roi des synthétiseurs anglais
ou les rois anglais des synthétiseurs
répondent à la question comme vous le souhaitez, vous
savez que
j'ai beaucoup apprécié l'expérience très intéressante
est-il vrai que euh pour obtenir le vrai
style rock and roll quelque chose que vous n'êtes
évidemment pas  habitué à
l'animalerie  Les garçons vous ont dit que vous
ne pouviez plus sourire.
et j'étais tellement ravi d'être
là-haut j'étais un peu comme ça
et après je suis sorti après la
répétition j'ai dit alors qu'en pensez-vous
neal il a dit que c'était absolument merveilleux
ne souriez pas d'accord madame
est-ce vrai que  vous vous ennuyiez à chanter des
chansons qui ont été écrites avant votre
naissance
et que vous n'écoutiez que du rock and
roll à la maison je n'ai pas dit que
j'ai dit que vous êtes tous vous savez que vous êtes
tous
pareils vous ne faites jamais vos foutues recherches
tout le monde  ça ne me dérangerait pas d'
accord je vais répondre à la question je
pense vraiment que c'est une question stupide mais je
vais répondre à la question tu as probablement
dit ça quelque part ce n'est pas de ma faute
tu ne te souviens pas de ce que tu as
dit  je suis né parce que t  hey parle
d'émotions qui continuent après
ma naissance et après ma mort
essayez de le trouver et
peu importe quand il a été écrit
pour quelqu'un qui est allé au centre betty ford
c'est tres amisons de faire une reprise
de la torsion de tonita tigrum dans ma sobriété
parlez-moi de ce miel
bien pour vous dire la vérité je  comme
tout ce qui contient le mot sobriété,
je veux dire
que vous trouviez votre sobriété
[Musique]
betty ford center ou que vous la trouviez à
hazelton ou que vous la trouviez
ailleurs, vous la trouverez finalement en
vous-même,
vous savez et c'est ce qui vous permet de continuer
et c'est
gentil  de tranquillité d'esprit j'assimile ce mot
tranquillité d'esprit parce que la sobriété semble si
ennuyeuse vous savez que c'est comme si
c'était adulte mais ce n'est pas tout ce que
j'ai toujours recherché
est-il difficile d'être une légende vivante eh bien
vous voulez  dites à beaucoup de gens qu'est-ce que
je suis mort mais vous savez que je suis déjà mort de
quoi parlez-vous parce que vous
savez,
n'ai-je pas un peu plus de temps
avant d'écrire complètement
quelque chose sur moi et de me mettre ici
dans  une boîte quelque part
[Musique]
bleu